[MUSIC]
I'd like to ask you about GPA.
Stanford says that there’s no minimum GPA,
but can you get in with a low GPA?
I’d also like to know how you
evaluate GPAs outside of the US?
>> Both of those questions come
up from applicants often as well.
Again, the GPA is just one indicator, but
this one is about a four year period of
time often, a three or four year
period of time, so we do look at that.
For us, if you think about the GPA,
we know that
it's going to vary by institution,
the level of a GPA, also even by major.
Sometimes I find that highly rigorous
quantitative majors are sometimes
more science oriented, on average
students’ GPAs will be lower there.
So that’s something we’re
taking into consideration.
In addition,
if you think about international schools,
we don’t convert their
GPAs into US conversions.
We actually look at the country and
try to be familiar with what's
their educational system.
And recognize that oftentimes
international GPAs
are less inflated than US GPAs may be.
So all of that is for
you to realize that we're trying to do our
best to understand what they looks
like in your particular context.
That being said, if you look at
you transcript, and take it and
look at at it with fresh
eyes as an applicant, and
you see a point in time, a semester,
quarter, whatever it was,
where you don't think it reflects your
true capabilities, tell us about that.
We have an additional information section,
it could've been health,
it could've been a personal situation, but
we're looking for reasons to admit you,
not for reasons to deny.
So any context that you can give us to
help understand what your trajectory has
been would be really helpful.
>> That's great, I like the framing
of that too, we're looking for
reasons to admit us, not to deny us.
>> Excatly.
>> I think that's great.
>> And no applicant is going to be
outstanding in every dimension, [LAUGH].
So you put your best foot forward and
know that those strengths
are the important things